comme chaque jeudi je vous propose
maintenant un gros plan sur un thème de
campagne sur les propositions des
candidates et les candidats c'est
demandez le programme
demandez le programme sur l'âge des
retraites la réforme faut-il repousser
l'âge légal jusqu'à 65 ans ou travailler
moins longtemps jusqu'à 60 ans est un
vrai marqueur dans cette présidentielle
comme nous l'expliquent hugo lemonnier
à quel âge partir at on à la retraite la
question divise toutes les familles
politiques à gauche anne hidalgo et
yannick jadot s'accordent pour
sanctuariser le départ à la retraite à
62 ans tandis que le pcf et les insoumis
prône un retour à 60 ans mais
divergences de fond fabien roussel
propose de s'arrêter de travailler après
37,5 années de cotisations quand
jean-luc mélenchon souhaite un départ à
taux plein après quarante annuités
quelle est la situation réelle
aujourd'hui du pays les jeunes gens ont
pour la première fois un emploi en cdi
entre dans le boulot à 23 ans + 43
annuités égale 66 ans ça veut dire que
la génération montante travaillera
jusqu'à l'âge de 66 ans et vous savez
que moi que travailler trop longtemps
nuit à la santé à l'extrême droite deux
visions s'opposent eric zemmour se dit
favorable à un retour progressif de
l'âge de départ à la retraite à 64 ans
d'ici 2030 tandis que marine le pen elle
reste attachée au marqueur de la
retraite à 60 ans avec 40 annuités la
retraite à 60 ans ça ne veux si je puis
me permettre rien dire si on n'appuie
pas cette cet âge sur 40 annuités à 60
ans on a passé quarante annuités qu'est
ce qui se passe bien continuer à
travailler jusqu'à ce qu'on ait ces
quarante annuités du côté des lr valérie
pécresse propose de porter l'âge légal à
65 ans il faut travailler plus longtemps
donc oui bien sûr il faudra passer
progressivement à 64 puis à 60 55 c'est
une nécessité alors ça suppose ouais en
donnant donnant
de travailler évidemment sur les
carrières longues et sur la pénibilité
seul le président de la république
candidat non-déclaré entretient le flou
sur ses intentions il faudra travailler
plus longtemps dit-il mais il abandonne
son projet de retraite à points il faut
qu'on aille tous vers une sortie de ce
qu'on appelle les régimes spéciaux à 42
régime aujourd'hui alors est-ce qu'il en
faut un seul ce qui était mon projet
initial je crois que c'est trop
anxiogène mais je pense qu'il nous faut
aller vers un système simplifié ou pour
la fonction publique pour les salariés
et puis pour les indépendants on a au
somme au dos à 3-3 grands régimes laissé
en chantier par la majorité la réforme
des retraites sera en 2022 l'un des
enjeux de la présidentielle
et on va vraiment anglais ce débat sur
la question de l'âge légal faute il
repoussait l'avancé je vous propose deux
d'en débattre avec marie le bec bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes député à l'om des
yvelines la commission des finances à
l'assemblée othman nassr ou bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes porte parole de
campagne de valérie pécresse et vice
président de la région ile de france ian
brossât bonsoir soir directeur de
campagne
de fabien roussel maire adjoint de paris
alors en charge du logement de
l'hébergement d'urgence et de la
protection des réfugiés j'accueille
également en duplex en visioconférence
eric heyer qui est docteur en économie
et directeur du département analyse et
prévision de l'ofce observatoire
français des conjonctures économiques
bon soit eric heyer merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et lætitia
coupat évidemment il rester à mes côtés
je vais donner deux chiffres pour
commencer parce que 34% des français
déclarent ne pas connaître aujourd'hui
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite
c'est baromètre pour le cercle des
épargnants et sa date de l'an dernier
alors donné l'information tout de suite
l'âge légal c'est 62 ans et l'âge
effectif d'ailleurs de départ à la
retraite c'est 60 2,2 c'est le baromètre
de la drees qui nous donne ces
informations l'an dernier alors cet âge
légal mal de mecs en écoutant le
reportage du goût éloignés ou dire
entretient le flou c'est pas juste le
président entretient pas le fou sauf que
il a quand même changé pied peut-être
contraint et forcé par la crise qu vide
mais il a changé de pied je pense qu'on
a toujours une ligne très claire dans ce
qu'on voulait faire de cette réforme de
retraites c'est à la fois un système qui
est plus juste qui est plus lisible vous
l'avez très bien dit je pense que à la
fois les gens ne connaissent pas l'âge
de départ légal à la retraite mais
surtout ils connaissent pas la jaked et
non plus de décote ce qui est quand même
un élément important pour avoir votre
retraite à taux plein et puis ensuite un
système qui permet de corriger un
certain nombre des inégalités qui sont
entretenus aujourd'hui par le système
inégalités vis-à-vis des femmes
vis-à-vis des carrioles naufragés
ensuite est-ce que la situation
politique dans laquelle ou économique
dans laquelle nous avons été permet de
justifier un certain nombre d'évolutions
certainement le deuxième paramètre c'est
que cette question de la réforme des
retraites elle touche à la fois les
politiques qui vont décider les
organisations patronales et syndicales
qui sont aussi partie prenante du débat
les français aussi qui doivent être
concernés parce que c'est au final c'est
la vie de chacun qui est déterminé par
cette loi donc la question de l'âge de
départ je crois que c'est une question
qui est fondamentale sur tf1 décembre il
a dit qu'il fallait rencontrer et le
président a donné effectivement sa
position sur la nécessité de repousser
mais en gardant toujours finalement
cette même idée un régime plus simple
plus lisible et qui corrige les
inégalités tenaces trouve votre
candidate avait aussi nous faire
travailler plus longtemps l'a entendu
jusqu'à 65 ans 1 par étapes pourquoi
parce qu'on vit plus longtemps et qu'il
faut qu on équilibre ce régime des
retraites et moi je veux bien entendre
que les manuels a décidé de finalement
repousser l'âge de départ qu' macron ne
voulait pas repousser jusque là parce
qu'il a eu cinq ans pour le faire et
donc en réalité il a pris une lourde
responsabilité parce que aujourd'hui on
a un régime qui déséquilibrait avec 13
milliards de déficit on entre alors on
part plus tôt que la moyenne des pays
européens qui peut tout autour de 63,3
ici on est plutôt à 62,2 vous l'avais
dit à l'instant donc on a besoin de
l'équilibré et puis c'est la raison
aussi pour laquelle nous avons des
pensions qui sont aussi basse et dont
valérie pécresse elle est cohérente on
va travailler plus longtemps
progressivement jusqu'à 65 ans à
l'horizon 2030 mais en parallèle nous
aurons une revalorisation des pensions
pour qu' aucun retraités à taux plein ne
touchent moins que le smic ce qui est la
moindre des choses et donc il faut qu'on
corrige ces inégalités là mais en étant
extrêmement clair et extrêmement droit
dans ses bottes c'est à dire la retraite
à 65 ans alors c'est intéressant parce
qu'on a vraiment deux modèles qui vont
s'opposer ian brossât parce que votre
candidat lui défend et vous défendez une
retraite à 60 ans pourquoi oui nous
défendons la retraite à 60 ans pour une
raison simple c'est que nous ne
considérons pas que le rôle des
responsables politiques se doit être en
permanence de dégrader la vie des gens
notre rôle ce n'est pas de pourrir la
vie des gens notre rôle ce n'est pas de
faire que les gens meurent au travail
que ça et quand je vous dis ça je pense
par exemple à se salarier d'amazones de
63 ans qui bossait dans un entrepôt et
qui est mort d'une crise cardiaque au
travail ça n'est pas mon modèle de
société hoyé et je pense qu'on peut
évidemment traiter ce sujet sous un
angle purement comptable ce n'est pas
qu'une question comptable c'est une
question de modèle de société quelle
société on veut vous savez quand on a
créé la sécurité sociale au lendemain de
la guerre dans un pays ruiné on n'a pas
commencé par se dire combien ça coûte on
a commencé par se dire hein c'est
nécessaire et comment on le finance dans
cet ordre là et je trouve que dans notre
pays nous souffrons du fait qu' on ne
met plus en oeuvre de réformes heureuse
toutes les réformes qui sont mises en
place sont toujours des réformes qui
visent à dégrader la vie des gens mais
je ne pense pas qu'on doit faire
mais comment vous financez je devance
les questions de
mes autres amis il peut parfaitement le
finance et qui a vidé les caisses de la
sécurité sociale qui passe son temps en
permanence à réduire les cotisations
sociales payées par les employeurs c'est
les différents gouvernements françois
hollande l'a fait avec le cic eu ce
gouvernement l'a fait en pérennisant les
baisses de cotisations sociales
évidemment que si vous vider les caisses
parce que vous réduisez les cotisations
et a plus d'argent pour le financer ses
21 milliards d'euros de cotisations
sociales en moins sur les employeurs
chaque année parce que nous disons c'est
que cet argent faut le remettre aux
quais est-ce que je peux poser une
question à lézinnes tous les toits pour
ça aussi c'est se pose par exemple si
vous dites nous voilà nous sert retraite
à 60 ans si on veut travailler plus
c'est possible ou pas mais vous l'avez
entendu tout à l'heure évidemment que
c'est possible puisque aujourd'hui vous
avez un âge de départ à la retraite de
62 ans et la moyenne c'est 60 05 2,2
donc ça
veut simplement les ondes plus de
simplement dire que vous avez la
possibilité évidemment de travailler
davantage mais que si vous exercez un
métier pénible vous pouvez partir et que
c'était la protection pour la 60 ans
parce que vous voyez quand même
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé
j'aimerais bien qu'on en parle c'est
soit les on va en parler on va en parler
un peu près deux ans aujourd'hui et donc
je vous interromps parce qu'il faut
aussi en tenir fait évidemment partie
des thèmes de deux étages et vous
redonner la parole mais je voudrais
entendre
eric heyer sur sur finalement ce qui est
intéressant dans ce débat c'est vraiment
de modèle qui qui s'opposent si on
regarde un peu vers nos voisins
européens
nassau disais tout à l'heure on est à
63,3 de moyenne il ya effectivement est
ce qu'il ya des pays d'europe qui comme
le propose ian brossât sont en train de
revenir vers 60 ans ou même moins qui
sait n'ont pas réellement c'est vrai que
là on va plutôt vers un allongement de
l'âge de départ à la retraite mais avec
aussi une paupérisation des retraités on
voit que effectivement tous ces pays ont
un taux de pauvreté des 65 enfin
nettement supérieurs aux nôtres ont ils
tournent aux alentours de 18 % de taux
de pauvreté chez les seniors quand en
france on est plutôt à 9% donc c'est
effectivement un choix de société c'est
bien des actifs qui financent un pouvoir
d'achat pour les inactifs bon avec de la
répartition donc ils ont ils ont acquis
des droits on consacre 14.2 pible là
dedans c'est aussi très élevée quand on
se compare mais on a un niveau de vie à
la retraite supérieures aux autres pays
un taux de pauvreté inférieur bon c'est
un c'est vraiment un choix je pense que
c'est mais c'est juste qu'à dit ian
brossât c'est économiquement on peut
régler les problèmes voyons ce que nous
dit le conseil d'orientation des
retraites c'est que ça serait financée à
l'horizon
2050 et même il y aurait des excédents à
2070 sans réforme vous voyez on peut on
pourrait tenir à peu près il ya quelques
années aujourd'hui à tenir mais mais
globalement il n'y a rien de d2 trop
catastrophique là dedans mais voilà
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec le taux
d'emploi des seniors qui est extrêmement
faible oui c'est des débats aussi qu'on
peut se poser en économie est ce que
rallonger l'âge de départ à la retraite
ça maintiendrait plus de personnes dans
l'emploi ou pas bon c'est des questions
je pense qu'il va falloir si on y va eh
ben ce qui se questionnaient sur comment
oran employables les seniors lorsqu'ils
ont 62 63 64 parce qu'on a un taux
d'emploi des seniors les plus faibles
aussi de quasiment tous ces grands pays
et la campagne présidentielle évidemment
c'est le meilleur moment pour se poser
ces questions et pour les tranchées via
le vote des électeurs laetitia sion
revient
si on regarde un petit peu dans le
rétroviseur et qu'on fait le bilan du
quinquennat du président cette réforme
c'est quoi c'est un peu la grande
promesse non tenue c'est le grand échec
vous êtes jusque là dans l'euphémisme
est évidemment emmanuel macron arrive à
l'elysée avec la promesse de cette
réforme entre autres ça devait être un
quinquennat de réformes alors bien sûr
qu'il a dû essuyer des crises que l'on
connaît mais françois hollande également
on avait essuyé aussi on va pas
commencer à hiérarchiser à chaque fois
tous les événements qui arrivent dans un
pays et qui sont par nature
difficilement prédictible donc en tout
cas cinq ans plus tard ce qu'on peut en
tant que français constater c'est que
rien n'a été fait que ça a été remis aux
calendes grecques et que là emmanuel
macron quand il prend la parole un peu
avant cette interview à tf1 le 9
novembre dans une allocution
présidentielle censée être sur le co vie
mais on comprend que finalement il va à
peu sur tous les sujets ils nous
annoncent carrément que ce sera pour
2022 c'est à dire pour la pole prochain
président ou la prochaine présidente
écoutez là
ne sont pas réunies pour relancer
aujourd'hui ce chantier
pour autant notre volonté de sauver
notre modèle par répartition et d'en
corriger des inégalités n'a pas changé
dès 2022 il faudra pour préserver les
pensions de nos retraités et la
solidarité entre nos générations prendre
des décisions claires est ce que cette
réforme peut être aussi un handicap pour
la candidature l'adéma neil mac bah oui
parce que 2022 alors apparemment son
équipe dit c'est bon c'est tranché il
sait ce qu'il va le faire mais enfin il
faut pas gagné l'élection juste avant de
peut-être potentiellement enfin mettre
en place cette réforme alors faut
écouter l'entourage alors ils disent oui
c'est un la campagne c'est vraiment une
bonne occasion justement pour trancher
définitivement cette question notamment
sur l'âge parce que l'âge c'est très
symbolique l'âge de départ à la retraite
et alors là est ce qu'ils les aider ou
handicapé par son ancien premier
ministre edouard philippe qui carrément
en septembre dit allez 67 ans dans son
interview au magazine challenge edouard
philippe qui avait porté cette réforme
avec 1 49 3 le brutal rappelez vous
avant de tout stopper et je passe aussi
dans celle un peu l'histoire je passe
dans ce feuilleton excusez moi mais
alors l'éviction de monsieur retraite
jean paul delevoye dans des encore bref
ça c'était encore un autre à notre
feuilleton mais c'est vrai que cette
réforme des retraites annoncée par
emmanuel macron en 2010 est
factuellement sans refaire l'histoire si
vous voulez n'a pas eu lieu bon le
caillou dans la chaussure non c'est pas
le cas déjà je crois qu'il ya un
principe de base c'est que pour financer
notre système de retraite il faut qu'il
ya des gens qui soient en activité
puisque ces actifs qui cotisent pour les
pour les inactifs pour avoir des gens
qui reviennent en activité il fallait
faire un certain nombre de réformes
économiques c'est ce qu'on a commencé à
faire dans le cadre de ce mandat est
aujourd'hui là là là le résultat est là
on a un chômage qui est en baisse et qui
n'a jamais été aussi bas depuis de très
nombreuses années et donc c'est que la
politique à la marche est ensuite
effectivement on a engagé à peu près à
mi mandat cette cette réforme des
retraites que je crois à une réforme
pour laquelle il faut accepter de
prendre du temps on veut tous sauver le
modèle par répartition mais pardon moi
je peux pas rejoindre les allaire qui
depuis des années nous nous baladent
avec des petites mesures d'âge sans
jamais ne s'attaquer réellement aux
problèmes de fond de ce système tel
qu'il a été bâti aujourd'hui on voit
bien valérie pécresse elle nous promet
un départ à 65 ans nous expliquant
qu'elle va revaloriser les petites
retraites mais quand on regarde dans son
programme quand elles passent dans des
émissions pour les présenter on voit
bien que son programme économique il est
complètement défaillant que rien ne
tient la route et que le et que le et
que le modèle tient pas je veux parler
dire vous refaites un peu l'histoire le
49-3 était utilisée parce que nos
oppositions dont les élèves n'ont pas
voulu de ce texte on allait poser on a
dû quand même des débattre on n'a pas pu
aller au bout parce que c'était trop
dense mais plus de 40 termine en c1 et
noir puisque façon plus dénaturer cette
réforme c'est une réforme qui est
difficile à engager c'est vrai et sur
lequel je pense il peut y avoir beaucoup
d'oppositions fait un travail de
pédagogie on a bien je vous avais mis en
cause les propositions de herri pécresse
je vous propose de répondre non je veux
juste rappeler à madame lebaye que les
républicains ne sont pas majoritaires à
l'assemblée nationale même si quand j'en
crois votre immobilisme sur ce sujet là
on pourrait penser que vous n'êtes pas
au pouvoir voilà donc vous dites depuis
quelques années les élèves ne l'ont pas
fait ça fait dix ans nous ne sommes plus
responsabilités et ça fait dix ans que
ce sujet pendant et en l'occurrence
c'est le premier quinquennat ne vont pas
de réforme des retraites depuis très
longtemps et ça c'est honnêtement
extrêmement préoccupant extrêmement
grave que vous n'ayez pas eu le courage
de faire adopter une réforme des
retraites quelle qu'elle soit parce que
effectivement c'est notre système par
répartition qui est aujourd'hui menacé
et je veux ajouter que les retraités
vont payer un lourd tribut aucun cas
d'emmanuel macron parce qu'il ya
l'absence de cette réforme des retraites
il y à la hausse de la csg et la
désindexation des pensions de retraite
se sont probablement ceux qui ont payé
le plus lourd tribut à ce quinquennat d'
emmanuel macron et donc quand j'entends
ce que je viens d'entendre je trouve que
c'est un petit peu un petit peu excessif
par contre monsieur brosnan a été très
habile en nous donnons pas de chiffrage
de la retraite à 60 ans est une
trentaine de milliards d'euros donc ce
que vous proposez c'est d'alourdir le
coût du travail dans notre pays deux
prix du travail peut-être très bien vous
vous placez systématiquement du bruit ou
ailleurs je sais tu salariés là c'est
toujours du côté de voiliers formule
alors y est le placent du côté des faits
et en l'occurrence en ce qui concerne un
jour hier dans nos opérateurs aux pme se
brosse en ce qui concerne les faits 30
milliards d'euros d'alourdissement la
vue prix du travail si vous voulez ça
donnera toujours la même conséquence ça
sera le chômage de masse parce que il
afut de compétitivité de nos entreprises
donc on est tous d'accord pour dire
effectivement que l'on veut que les gens
travaillent en bonne condition et bien
sûr qu'on tiendra compte des carrières
longues et de la pénibilité mais il faut
travailler plus longtemps si on veut
donner de meilleures retraites aussi
bien que nos personnes âgées votre
réponse sur le financement il ya
quelques questions à se poser d'abord
est-ce qu'on tient au système de
retraite par répartition nous nous
tenons au système de retraite par
répartition tout le monde le dit en tout
cas pour ce qui nous concerne les choses
sont claires deuxièmement est ce que le
système de retraite par répartition est
aujourd'hui en danger si j'en crois le
conseil d'orientation des retraites ça
n'est pas le cas ce que dit eric heyer
dictateur c'est ce qu'eric il ya 2000 se
sentait tout à l'heure en 2025 d'après
les estimations du conseil d'orientation
des retraites ça représenterait le
déficit représenterait 0,3 pour cent du
produit intérieur brut et on est en
train de nous dire qu'on va pourrir la
vie de tas de salariés qu'on va obliger
à travailler plus longtemps parce qu'on
a un déficit à horizon 2025 qui pèse
0,3 pour cent de notre pib puis vous
savez on dit beaucoup l'espérance de vie
s'est allongée au cours des dernières
décennies donc il faut travailler plat
l'ordre ça j'ajouterai quand même hein
et les remparts les voyez que si on
compare notre produit intérieur brut
nous richesses par rapport à ses
dernières décennies elles ont aussi
énormément augmenté parce que les
travailleurs ont bossé qu'ils ont
produit des richesses supplémentaires
ils doivent donc pouvoir en bénéficier
et avoir un peu plus de la loire entre
l'espérance de vie voilà deux chapitres
qu'on va ouvrir maintenant et pour
démarrer je vous propose d'écouter le
président du medef geoffroy roux de
bézieux y met en avant justement cette
plante temps que l'espérance de vie
augmente faut accepter de travailler
plus longtemps comme le font tous les
pays autour de nous à l'allemagne est à
67 je croyais même parle de le ballon
j'ai donc il faut le fait la démographie
ne ment pas et la démographie c'est que
quand on a fait ce système de retraite
par répartition la répartition en un mot
c'est les actifs qui payent pour les
retraités quand on a imaginé ce système
en 45 avec quatre actifs pour un
retraité on avance tout doucement vers
1.718 et à partir de 2040
malheureusement on aura un problème donc
oui ça paraît difficile en même temps en
1981 quand le président mitterrand a
fait la retraite à 60 ans on avait dix
sept ans d'espérance de vie à la
retraite tous métiers confondus
aujourd'hui on a plus de 30
l'espérance de vie augmente elle tant
que ça on va y répondre tout de suite
avec laurent mauriac bonsoir à laurent
vous êtes bienvenu vous êtes le
rédacteur en chef de brief mis notre
paratonnerre dans cette campagne
présidentielle c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être l'argument qu'on entend le
plus souvent oui et c'est vrai que le
l'espérance de vie ne cesse de
s'allonger en france
rien qu entre 2014 et 2019 donc hors
effet qu'ovide des hommes ont gagné six
mois d'espérance de vie et les femmes
deux mois et demi donc c'est un argument
qu'on entend effectivement souvent par
exemple anciens premiers ministres
edouard philippe le manier dans son
interview à challenges le en septembre
et il disait chacun comprend bien que si
l'espérance de vie augmente la durée de
la vie active doit aussi progresser
est-ce que cet indicateur dont on se
sert les uns les hôtesses qui n'est
suffisamment précis alors il ya des
indicateurs plus pertinents certains ont
déjà été évoquées par exemple
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé c'est
à dire en comptant seulement les années
où l'on n'est pas limité dans ses
activités quotidiennes et là on
s'aperçoit qu'elle s'allonge aussi mais
plus lentement on peut aussi regarder
l'espérance de vie à partir de 65 ans
c'est à dire à partir de l'âge où on on
peut partir à la retraite et là encore
elle s'allonge mais à un rythme plus
faible que l'espérance de vie la
naissance et si on parle des inégalités
quel est l'impact qu'elles ont sur
l'espérance de vie alors là les
disparités sont très très fortes au sein
de la population par exemple entre les
cadres et les ouvriers et voici ce qu'en
disait le député la france insoumise
adrien cadenassent à public sénat en
octobre dernier
il ya une négation absolue du fait que
par exemple entre un cadre et un ouvrier
vous avez six années d'écart d'espérance
de vie entre les 5% les plus riches et
les 5 % les plus pauvres ces treize
années d'écart d'espérance de vie est ce
que ces chiffres sont bons oui ces
chiffres sont bons ce sont les chiffres
de l'insee et alors c'est il parle en
fait de 13 années c'est pour les hommes
et dont voici un graphique qui montre
ces disparités en fonction du revenu
donc on voit que plus le revenu
progresse quand on va de la gauche vers
la droite plus la courbe de l'ailé de
l'espérance de vie s'élève et on
retrouve bien l'écart de 13 années pour
les hommes dont on parle adrien 4,9
alors en cause dans cet écart il ya deux
choses il ya les habitudes de vie par
exemple les le tabagisme la consommation
d'alcool ou l'activité physique mais il
ya aussi les conditions de travail et
donc la question se pose pour toute
future réforme des retraites de savoir
s'il faut ou non prendre en compte ces
inégalités et chercher à les corriger
merci laurent pour pour toutes ces
précisions ian brossât c c'est pour ça
que vous proposez un départ à la
retraite encore plus tôt l'âge légal ce
serait 60 ans mais vous proposer un
départ à la retraite encore plus tôt
pour certaines professions lesquels
regarder effectivement l'espérance de
vie en bonne santé pour un ouvrier ses
59 ans c'est à dire que même si vous
décidez de mettre en place l'âge de
départ à la retraite à 60 ans ça veut
dire qu'un ouvrier n'aura pas une année
en retraite en bonne santé c'est quand
même un sujet est ce qu'on considère
normal que des gens ne puissent pas
bénéficier d'une année de deux années en
retraite avec une santé convenable qui
lui permet de profiter de sa retraite
donc oui effectivement pour les
professions qui exercent des métiers
pénibles et c'est le cas des ouvriers en
tout cas de la grande majorité d'entre
eux on devrait avoir la possibilité de
partir avant ça me paraît être ça me
paraît être le bon sens je pose la
question parce que la difficulté c'est
toujours de définir il ya des effets de
seuil à des professions qui vont
réclamer qu'ils l'auront pas la liste va
être difficile à établir votre
chroniqueur disait les choses très
justement la démographie ne ment pas et
en l'occurrence l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé c'est un bon indicateur et
quand vous regardez effectivement
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé 59 ans
pour un ouvrier 69 ans pour un cadre
donc vous avez un monde entre ces deux
entre ces deux catégories la salle pas
dire que c'est facile d'être cadre c'est
aussi du stress pour ça mais en tout cas
si on représente les ouvriers ouvriers
c'est environ 20% de la population
active ce qui n'est pas tout à fait rien
ça les ont parfois je pose juste la
question pour compliquer
quand on est par exemple certains
vendeurs
c'est parfois quand on écoute un certain
nombre de commentateurs on a
l'impression que le monde ouvrier a
disparu le monde ouvrier a pas disparu
c'est un actif sur cinq est ce sont des
hommes et des femmes qui ont méritent
des réponses notamment sur cette
question des retraites telle est la
phrase de démographiquement passé c'est
pas à laurent mais c'est geoffroy roux
de bézieux
il arrive
même s'il dit que la lune est ronde je
vais pas dire qu'elle est triangulaire
il disait tout à l'heure au moment où
françois mitterrand décide de la
retraite à 60 ans la situation n'était
pas la même juste un détail à l'époque
les patrons des patrons étaient déjà
qu'on montre qu'il allait retenir à
l'époque ça posait pas de problème ici
opposé déjà avec beaucoup de virus la
pénibilité et les professions pour
lesquelles éventuellement on pourrait
choisir un âge un âge légal de départ
différent ça pose la question de la
multiplication des régimes est
effectivement l'une des volontés du
présent république c'était de sortir de
ce magma 42 régime etc il propose
c'était toujours dans cette interview à
tf1 trois grands régimes c'est ça c'est
l'idée oui alors le président
effectivement dans le cadre de l'udps
interview à tf1 a dit m'a peut-être que
faire converger tout le monde vers un
seul régime c'est un peu compliqué et ça
peut générer des angoisses et des
carrières qui sont différentes qui ont
gardé une structure avec trois grands
régimes mais on passerait quand même de
42 à 3 c'est quand même pas rien en
termes de simplification et après
c'était le cadre des débats mais mais ça
pourra évoluer en fonction de 2 la
nouvelle mouture qui sera proposé mais
ce qui avait été proposé c'est à dire
aussi en fait on fait un système par
points et c'est au nombre de points que
vous accumulez et quand vous avez par
exemple un métier pénible vous accumulez
un peu davantage de points ce qui
justifie en fait que vous puissiez avoir
un départ qui soit anticipée par rapport
à d'autres professions où effectivement
on considère qu'en fonction du métier
que vous exercez vous n'avez pas la même
pénibilité donc vous ne vous n'avez pas
les mêmes conditions
de travail je crois que ça pose aussi
c'est l'intérêt de l'interview du
président réplique de rappeler qu' on
peut toujours parler de l'allongement de
la durée dans l'emploi c'est un vrai
sujet je pense à un vrai sujet de
financements la question de l'emploi
senior tant qu'on a pas résolue tant
qu'on n'a pas apporté une réponse ça
restera un poids je pense dans la mise
en place de cette réforme aujourd'hui on
connaît tous dans nos eaux tourage des
gens qui ont d'abord été mis au chômage
et puis comme vous avez passé un certain
âge vous l'avez souvent trois années de
chômage et puis ensuite vous prenez le
plan de départs oulahlou la pré retraite
et donc en fait ça s'est allongée l'âge
6 s'il n'y a pas de marché
je crois que c'est une bonne réflexion
pour nous obliger aussi à considérer
caisse comment est-ce qu'on emploie les
seniors dans la société moi j'ai fait un
tour dans ma circonscription parce que
c'est un sujet qui nous qui nous
préoccupaient et voyez j'ai constaté que
par exemple dans l'industrie dans les
professions industrielles on est
beaucoup plus on travaille beaucoup lu
sur l'adaptation du poste à des seniors
que chez les cadres où finalement on
s'est pas tellement bien quoi en faire
et on a tendance à dire bon bah ça coûte
cher à l'entreprise on va les sortir
donc je pense que c'est un vrai sujet de
société aussi pour la place que l'on
accorde à nos seniors la place que l'on
donne à nos aînés l'utilité sociale
aussi et pas considérer que quand vous
passez une barrière d'âge et bien
finalement vous êtes soit trop cher soit
un peu désuet soit tout casser et donc
on n'a plus besoin de vous dans
l'entreprise et on va rester sur la
pénibilité je vais vous donner la parole
sur ce thème précis mais eric heyer sur
sur effectivement l'emploi des seniors
j'aimerais bien avoir votre votre
expertise est ce que la situation elle
est plutôt en train de s'améliorer ou au
contraire de s'aggraver en france
alors oui alors cette chouette est un
point faible on a toujours été pas très
bon dans les taux d'emploi à la fois des
jeunes et des seniors les seniors les
jeunes si jusqu'à 1 24 ans et les
seniors ça commence à 55 ans et donc on
a toujours été très en retrait par
rapport aux autres pays développés
notamment les autres pays européens et
aujourd'hui on est en train de rattraper
en partie ce retard alors on peut
peut-être
lemaitre 6 e au profit des réformes des
retraites on a eu un certain nombre
c'est possible à certaines études
économiques qui tente de mettre ce lien
là on en n'est pas complètement sûr mais
pourquoi pas et aujourd'hui on est cam
56 % de taux d'emploi en france c'est à
dire aller quasiment globalement un
senior sur deux est déjà au chômage donc
augmenter l'âge de départ à la retraite
ça veut dire qu'on lui rallonge la
période au chômage et donc alors que
dans les autres pays oui en allemagne on
est à 72 % de taux d'emploi des seniors
donc il ya très peu de chômage à cet âge
là est donc un rallongement et c'est
moins complète donc oui effectivement si
on devait aller pour des raisons
paramétrique vers un augmentation une
augmentation de l'âge de départ à la
retraite il va falloir accompagner par
une politique de l'emploi et de l'emploi
des seniors sinon finalement on ferait
des économies sur les retraites mais on
creuserait les déficits par le chômage
par aussi ça a été relativement bien
montré par le conseil d'orientation des
retraites par d'autres coûts qui sont un
peu des dix essais la pénibilité donc on
tombe un peu plus malades c'est
également plus de rs a donc au final on
serait très déçu par les économies que
nous procurer à un rallongement
effectivement je les ai cessé ces
chiffres eric heyer
c'est l'adresse pour le conseil
d'orientation des retraites ça date du 3
janvier dernier
les conséquences d'un relèvement de
l'âge à 64 ans donc ce serait plus deux
ans pour l'âge légal plus 3,6 milliards
d'euros de prestations sociales dont un
milliard huit pour les pensions
d'invalidité 970 millions pour les
indemnités de sécurité sociale 830
millions pour les minima sociaux et les
cas je reste avec vous ça veut dire que
ça coûte plus cher en prestations
sociales mais est-ce que ce qu'est ce
que ça rapporte ans en cotisations en
consommation
alors oui alors on est vraiment il faut
faire très attention à ça sic alors vous
avez peut-être on peut rajouter aussi un
chômage qui augmente et donc nous dit
core 1,4 milliard de de suppléments en
assurant chômage donc ça fait à peu près
5 milliards de surcoûts mais d'un autre
côté on a économisé 14 milliards de
pensions donc oui il ya un petit gars
même positif mais attention avec un
chômage plus élevé et une pénibilité qui
provoque non que oui ça fait des petits
gars a fait ça fait bien s'appeler 10
milliards de toute manière c'est bien le
but recherché mais avec des effets qui
sont quand même plus faible qu'attendu
et tout cela avec une idée de gamme le
taux d'emploi augmenterait légèrement
baissé pour répondre à votre question en
fait on n'est pas sûr au final que cela
fasse augmenter le taux d'emploi des
seniors est donc rapportent des
cotisations supplémentaires alors c'est
pour ça que si vous l'accompagnez d'une
politique de l'emploi mais il est
possible qu'il y ait des cotisations
supplémentaires et donc bas moins de
dépenses plus de cotisations vous
arrivez à financer dès à présent votre
système parce qu'encore une fois
effectivement il est il est financé à
l'horizon de 2050 et magna déjà des
excédents aux réformes en 2070 ça veut
dire qu'est ce qu'on fait de ses
excédents plus tard est-ce qu'on leur
distribue mais attention on va
finalement faire des économies d'un côté
pour une certaine caisse et provoquer un
déséquilibre dans d'autres cas c'est
merci avec ail et la pénibilité j'y
reviens comme promis on a trouvé vos
propositions en la matière oui parce que
je suis entièrement d'accord avec elle
brosse à quand il dit qu'il ya des
métiers pénibles qu'ils méritent de
partir plus tôt personne le contraire ce
n'est pas le même débat que celui de
l'âge de départ légal qui s'appliquent
en matière de droit commun et donc oui
mais tiendront compte de la pénibilité
nous tiendrons compte des carrières
longues mais ceux qui ont des métiers
pénibles doivent pouvoir partir plus de
manière précoce et ça c'est tout à fait
normal j'ajoute que d'ailleurs on nous
explique on a un système qui est
généreux aujourd'hui on parle à 37 % de
nos retraites qui touche moins de 1000
euros donc la paupérisation non au
traité la question des conditions de vie
il se pose déjà dans le système actuel
avec l'âge de départ actuel est donc
repousser l'âge de départ légal
progressivement encore une fois d'ici à
2030 ça n'est pas ça ne produit pas les
effets que j'entends depuis tout à
l'heure la preuve c'est que mon voisin à
l'onf est en moi je veux bien croire
qu'on est le seul pays à avoir raison
seul contre tous mais nos voisins l'ont
fait et les taux d'emploi des seniors
font parfois meilleure que chez nous ça
a été dit s'agissant de l'allemagne
d'ailleurs nous proposons aussi avec
valérie pécresse le cumul
emploi-retraite la possibilité pour les
retraités qui le souhaite doit avoir un
emploi dans des conditions favorables et
ça c'est aussi une source de recettes de
recettes fiscales pour l'état donc il
faut ne pas voir les choses d'une
manière malthusienne le travail moi je
toujours pensé qu'il ne se partageaient
pas comme certains veulent le faire
croire il faut qu'on libère les énergies
et il faut qu'on surtout on assure
l'équilibré de notre système de
retraites si on est sincèrement attachés
au système par répartition il y a un
tout dernier sujet ce sujet les pensions
de réversion des veuves et des veufs de
personnes qui ont qui avaient droit à
une pension de retraite qui est
aujourd'hui indigne puisqu'on a
seulement 54 % de la pension qui reste
et nous voulons augmenter de 40% ses
pensions là mais c'est parce que nous
allons faire cette réforme courageuse
que nous allons pouvoir donner une
meilleure condition de vie à leurs
traités alors j'aimerais qu'on termine
sur la question de notre endettement de
l'équilibré de nos finances publiques j
en écoutant bruno le maire le ministre
de l'économie c'est l'argument principal
qu'ils donnent régulièrement dans des
interviews et notamment lorsqu'il était
auditionné ici au sénat pourquoi
prolonger l'âge de la retraite voilà ce
que dit bruno le maire s'était le
premier ferry faut des réformes de
structure
nous avons commencé avec la réforme de
l'assurance chômage me semble
indispensable de poursuivre avec la
réforme des retraites qui doit être une
priorité absolue pour le rétablissement
de nos finances publiques et de finances
sociales en particulier est ce que
l'oubli une logique uniquement
économiques non je tiens vraiment le
préciser il s'agit aussi de simplifier
d'avoir un système qui soit plus juste
notamment pour ceux qui ont démarré tôt
dans leur vie active mais c'est pas
l'objet de notre discussion aujourd'hui
mais je tiens à préciser qu
effectivement ce n'est pas le seul
objectif de la réforme des retraites à
ian brossât vous êtes évidemment opposé
à 7
à cette idée à ce projet comment comment
rééquilibrer nos finances publiques sans
allonger l'âge du départ légal c'est
très révélateur ce que dit bruno le
maire parce qu'il prend l'exemple de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage cette
réforme de l'assurance chômage qui de
fait a conduit à réduire l'indemnisation
des chômeurs et ses looks il nous dit on
a fait la réforme de l'assurance chômage
maintenant il faut s'attaquer à la
réforme des retraites c'est exactement
ce que je vous disais au début de
l'émission ce ne sont que des réformes
qui visent à aggraver la situation des
plus modestes systématiquement tout le
temps un rôle aussi dans le retour à
l'emploi des personnes non parce que je
ne pense pas que les gens qui sont au
chômage rêve d'être au chômage je pense
que leur raid c'est travailler et ça
suppose évidemment qu'on crée de
l'emploi mais c'est quand même une
question fondamentale dans un pays aussi
riche que le nôtre qui est la sixième ou
septième puissance économique du monde
on a des responsables politiques qui
n'engagent de réformes que pour pourrir
la vie des gens et donc ce que nous
disons avec fabien roussel c'est que
dans un pays aussi riche que le nôtre on
devrait être capable de mettre en oeuvre
des réformes progressistes si on a été
capable de le faire dans un pays ruiné
au lendemain de la seconde guerre
mondiale on doit être capable de le
faire aujourd'hui en france je crois que
la question de l' équilibre financier
elle dépasse la question de la bonne
gestion de l'état c'est aussi un sujet
de confiance de la population dans le
système de retraite je constate
aujourd'hui trop souvent que au vu de
l'état de notre système de retraite
beaucoup pensent qu'ils n'auront pas
accès à cette retraite que finalement
eux mêmes alors qu'ils cotisent pour
leurs aînés ne bénéficiant pas je crois
que ça ça cette rupture de confiance ça
risque de se mettre en fragilité notre
système par répartition je suis très
attaché à ce système je pense que c'est
ce qu'il faut forcément le réformer pour
tenir cette promesse oui je pense
qu'elle est nécessaire parce que
effectivement on l'a vu il ya un
allongement de la durée de vie on a
diminution du nombre de personnes en
activité par rapport au nombre de
personnes inactives donc il y à des
paramètres goethe accord avec ian
brossât sur le fait dire il faut que les
gens puissent profiter de leur retraite
dans de bonnes conditions de santé mais
je crois qu'il faut aussi considérer
qu'il ya un certain nombre de paramètres
qui doivent permettre de faire que ce
que ce système de retraite soit
soutenable si on le rend peu soutenable
in fine il disparaîtra donc au delà de
la question de la bonne gestion des
deniers publics est un vrai enjeu je
crois que la question de dire comment
est ce qu'on fait pour que le système
soit pérenne dans le temps et il est
absolument fondamentale on avait fait
dans le cadre de la de la première
tentative de passer cette réforme une
conférence de financement je crois
qu'elle est aussi intéressante parce
qu'elle met à contribution les
partenaires sociaux pour savoir quelles
sont les différentes voies de
financement et le crois pas qu'il faille
forcément se priver de poursuivre quand
on relancera cette réforme des retraites
cette discussion avec les partenaires
sociaux othman à ce sera quoi le
imaginons valérie pécresse
devienne président de la république ce
sera une des premières réformes de son
de son quinquennat de son mandat et puis
avec quel processus parce
qu'effectivement on a parlé beaucoup des
partenaires sociaux mais ils vont jouer
un rôle majeur oui et quand on parle
précisément de la pénibilité ou les
carrières longues il faudra associer les
partenaires sociaux à la concertation
préalable mais c'est une réforme qui
doit arriver très vite et quand on parle
de crise de confiance comme je l'entends
à l'instant je ne peux pas être élu avec
un projet de réforme ne pas le faire
expliquait en fin de quinquennat comme
le fait manuel magro que finalement on
en fera peut-être une autre et dont on
sait aujourd'hui absolument rien tout
cela n'est pas sérieux enfin moi je suis
pas tout à fait d'accord avec laeticia
qui dit tout à l'heure tous les prêts
dans une des crises là quand même et ça
empêche de s'empêcher le parlement de se
réunir non non on peut comprendre qu'on
peut comprendre que c'est tout mais a
été reporté je ne le comprends
absolument pas c'était un engagement
2017 l'équilibré des retraites
aujourd'hui il est quand même menacé
parce que même si l'ue conseil
d'orientation des retraites donne des
perspectives elles sont incertaines et
pour l'instant nous avons un déficit de
13 milliards et le prénom de rugby
commence à faire voter une réforme il a
laissé tomber il nous explique
aujourd'hui que finalement ça n'était
peut-être pas la bonne et qu'on est elle
verrait pour le quinquennat suivant il
faut pas s'étonner qu'ils de
l'abstention dans notre pays quand un
responsable de politique qui prend des
engagements ensuite eh bien tout
simplement leur tourner le dos à ses
lettres à sa propre parole ça n'a aucun
sens mais le site souhaite une politique
de gribouille on ne sait pas où on va
nous sommes clairs ça demande du courage
mais je veux le dire la réforme ça n'est
pas forcément du sang et des larmes une
réforme ça peut être aussi du
gagnant-gagnant travail à celle une
réponse à ian brossât oui travailler
plus mais effectivement pour avoir de
meilleures retraites et avoir un système
équilibré et cessa l'engagement de
valérie pécresse et ça c'est sérieux
c'est du solide et je crois que c'est ce
dont on a besoin sur ce sujet dont on
parle à chaque fois depuis trop
longtemps vous sous-entendez ce que
propose enfin mersen n'est pas sérieux
donc il ya de l'argent magique n'existe
pas si j'entends que je vous le jure et
aller chercher à s'entendre
pourquoi pas c'est 35 il faut aller
chercher des conséquences et je pense
que beaucoup de français ont compris sur
ce sujet là et que ça n'était pas le
droit et on a même le droit othman nassr
ou de ne pas défendre exactement les
mêmes intérêts et j'assume avec fabien
roussel de défendre les intérêts des
travailleurs et des plus modestes c'est
effectivement une différence que nous
avons avec valérie la grèce et je
l'assumé il arrive qu'en voulant les
défendre on les enfonce allés chacun pas
venu s'exprimer j'avais beaucoup enfoncé
maire sait si au fond aux uns et aux
autres d'avoir débattu sur ce thème dans
ce sens public ici et merci eric heyer
évidemment d'autres expertises
en visioconférence je vous dis à lundi
pour le prochain numéro de science
publique